what's going on reject nation 14 we are
in the car right now we just got out of
seeing Tomb Raider we are planning on
doing a full movie review for you guys
but with a big group of people and most
of us felt pretty much the same about it
this is the best video game movie that
has come out so far most solid film
based on it absolutely like it is a
solid entertaining good time and the
reason I'm doing this video we really
want you guys to go check this movie
yeah this movie is just a solid good
time it's just a solid entertaining time
there's great action in it and the most
importantly the characters are really
good Alicia vikander she's written well
and man does she kill it in this movie
dude yes she gets rich is a good jack
like Bill but she gets freaking oh she
she's ripped in this movie believe she
is strong beyond that though she is just
a fully lived in performance she feels
like a real human being in this movie
and and that was the most important part
was that she just felt like a real human
being Walton Goggins is good in it
Dominic West is good in it Daniel Wu is
really good in it this film is just a
really solid entertaining time yeah it
has set a bar for video game movies this
is a great first step for video game
movies absolutely and I really want you
guys to go check this movie out I don't
know what rod tomatoes is gonna say
about this movie telling you guys right
now from John and I we really enjoyed
the hell out of this film so please go
watch it and let us know what you think
once the movie is out